It goes without saying that the beginning of the 21st century may be called an
age of amazing achievements in science and technology,
the launch of the ingenuity rotorcraft and Mars is one of the most recent
groundbreaking events by now,
the helicopter has completed several test flights,
and now let's look at each of them more closely
Cozmo. The first outer space,
the first flight took place on the 19th of April, 2021.
That is when ingenuity roses high as three meters above the planet surface and
hovered there for 40 seconds.
The helicopter also took the first black and white image using its navigation
camera.
The next flight took place on the 22nd of April,
as it was completing its task,
ingenuity roses high up as 4.9 meters this time and stayed up there
for 51 seconds. In that short time,
the chopper took its first color images and here is what they look
like
In these images. Wheel tracks left by the persevere and smiles over can be seen
By putting together the acquired images, scientists at NASA.
So I created a short film, demonstrating ingenuity, hovering above the surface.
The next objective to reach was the third test flight,
which was successfully completed on the 25th of April.
With this time ingenuity rose 5.2 meters high,
and then it flew around 50 meters parallel to the Marsha surface before safely
returning to the starting point.
This is what it looked like from the position of perseverance.
The Rover managed to take pictures and record a video.
The flight from its vantage point.
The,
the,
the.
And that's what the third flight looked like from ingenuity camera.
Interestingly, ingenuity developed a record speed of two meters per second.
In the course of the flight with all these indicators,
NASA was able to officially announce that the helicopter had successfully dealt
with all the planned tasks.
However, NASA decided not to stop there,
carry on with test flights with the next one taking place on the 30th of April.
In the course of this flight ingenuity negotiated a staggering
226 meters within 117 seconds.
Moving parallel to the surface,
thus beating its record and performing twice as well. This time,
this had achievement was captured by perseverance as cameras too.
Naturally.
All these encouraging achievements prompted the mission managers to set new
objectives for ingenuity. Right now,
the helicopter is about to test functions that might be beneficial for future
investigations of Mars.
The new phase will start after the helicopter has completed its sixth test
flight. And since ingenuity is still in mint condition,
NASA intends to continue using it to assist the perseverance Rover in its
explorations. After its sixth test flight,
the helicopter will have about two weeks to prepare for a new set of operations
demonstrations,
focusing on test technology tests in all of its previous flights.
This time ingenuity will move on to demonstrating its functions. For example,
apart from one way,
flights ingenuity will experiment with precision maneuvering,
which will enable it to cover larger areas of observation.
Besides at the next phase,
attempts will be made to give it more autonomy so that it relies on assistance
of the perseverance Rover team as little as possible.
This means that perseverance will be able to get on with its chief task
collecting samples of marsh and rocks and sediments. As for ingenuity,
it has plans to be aiding the Rover in coordinating its movements. To that end,
the helicopter will execute short flights accompanying the Rover.
This strategy will allow it to collect aerial imagery of the Rover's targets as
well as to promptly work out the Rover's potential roots to way points on the
fly. Interestingly,
these reconnaissance flights haven't been initially planned for ingenuity.
This aerial scouting is a kind of bonus that the MAs Rover team will benefit
from and will be able to reach their signs goals more efficiently.
As for the frequency of the helicopters flights,
they will be considerably less numerous this next phase with one test
flight every several days in late April ingenuity will now set out once
every two or three weeks,
the flights themselves are going to be planned in a way that they will not
interfere with perseverance science operations.
Thus,
the mission team is currently planning to assess the effectiveness of such like
flying air Mars and new portion of data.
Beamed bagged by ingenuity will provide new insights into what the next
generation of many helicopters on Mars should be like. The test flights,
meanwhile are scheduled until around the end of August.
If all of them are completed successfully,
NASA will be able to draw conclusions from the ingenuity and proceed to develop
new aircraft of this kind.
We in our turn will keep you posted on the mission's updates.
If you'd like us to carry on bringing you the latest news,
feel free to let us know in the comments or just hit the like button by way of
saying yes and let's keep in touch.
The.